Hey,
listen,
when most people think of success or
failure,
they think of these big giant things,
but failure is not an overnight
experience and neither is success.
Failure was the result of failure to
make the calls.
Failure to follow through.
Failure to say,
I love you.
Failure to give 100% that creates
ultimate failure in life.
The feelings we want to avoid it almost
all costs and yet successes also one
step at a time.
It's successfully making the call and
successfully getting herself up and
following through it successfully.
Making sure you make that unique.
Contact it successfully breaking through
the limits that used to stop you.
It's the culmination of all those little
successes over a lifetime that
eventually creates a life that we have
total pride and joy knowing is our own,
and I'm here to tell you that anything
you focus on,
on a consistent basis,
you put 100% of yourself into and you
can try and prove daily on you will
improve,
you will get better.
The problem is most of us in life do not
control the power of our mental focus.
In fact,
most of us focused on things like,
well,
Gosh,
how come my life isn't working?
How come this always happens to me?
And if you focus on that enough,
that's exactly what you'll experience in
life.
Whatever we focus on consistently,
we tend to manifest in our lives.
Don't you already believe that my
hallucination is you already do or you
wouldn't have picked up a tape program
like this?
The key is getting ourselves to live by
these factors.
You know,
most people in life,
major and minor things that is,
they're focused on how to make a living
instead of how to design their life.
You may be wondering what drove me to
want to really study success in this
level of depth.
In fact,
a lot of people say to me,
Tony,
how did you become so successful?
While I'm complimented by the statement,
but my response usually is the same
thing that drives all of us to succeed.
One of two experiences,
either inspiration or desperation.
For me,
it was more desperation.
I grew up in an environment I did not
like and it started back as far as high
school.
For me.
I remember looking around and being
dissatisfied.
And by the way,
if you're dissatisfied with some area of
your life right now,
instead of being frustrated,
get excited,
cause I got to tell you something.
Until you get dissatisfied,
you won't do anything to really make
your life at another level.
Dissatisfaction is a gem.
If you're totally satisfied,
you're going to get comfortable and then
your life begins to deteriorate.
But I found myself dissatisfied with my
environment.
I didn't like what I saw growing up.
I saw my father working extremely hard
as a salesman,
40 or 50 hours a week.
And yet most of the time we were broke
and I didn't understand why.
I remember what that did to them
emotionally.
And that drove a lot enough pain inside
of me that I thought to myself at that
time,
I don't want to ever have my family have
to go through this and I don't wanna
have to go through it myself ever again.
I thought someday I'm going to master
financial success so I can only help
myself,
but the people around me,
and that was a driving force for my
success in that area.
I remember going to high school and that
was not a real popular kid,
but I really love people and I being
around them and I wanted everybody to
like me and a lot of people did,
but I wasn't the most popular kid in
school.
But you know,
I thought some day I'm going to meet the
most popular kid in school and I'm going
to find out what makes them so popular.
He's probably one of the nicest,
most warm and genuine people you could
ever meet.
I remember the day I met this kid,
he treated me like I was dirt.
Like how dare I enter his space?
And I thought,
how could somebody who's this rude be
this successful and having people like
him and it made me want to study what
makes people like other people.
I remember looking around at people in
relationships,
people been married five,
10 15 years who are just hanging out
together.
They still have that passion that drive
for each other.
They really loved each other 100% it's
like they were newlyweds.
I remember one day going to my mother
and saying,
how come this is my fourth father?
I'm just curious,
and she told me an explanation that they
didn't quite understand at the time,
but I can tell you one thing,
it motivated me to want to make
relationships work.
So out of all of these things,
what happened for me in my mind is I
said,
look,
I don't like the way my life is.
I want to make it better.
And so somewhere in my mind I linked up
that what I should do is study success.
And if you want anything in life,
you've got to make it a study.
If you want to be successful,
you've got to study it,
not leave it to chance.
If you want to be happy,
you've got to study happiness.
If you want to be wealthy,
you've got to study wealth.
If you want to be healthy,
you've got to study health.
You can't just hope that things will
turn out okay.
You can see what hoping does for most
people,
most people don't have what they want
and they just keep hoping it will
change.
The bottom line for me is I went out and
started studying success like a madman.
I believe that if you will immerse
yourself and focus on anything,
you're going to get good at it and so I
decided to get good at understanding how
to make my life work and I went out and
read almost 700 books in the area of
human development.
Everything from your basic positive
thinking to your more esoteric forms of
change.
When I find I was so sophisticated,
the point is this,
as they read all this material and I
listened to tapes constantly in my car,
anytime I could,
I tried to dump some good stuff into my
mind.
I went to seminar after seminar after
seminar.
Many of them were lousy,
but my attitude was half.
I go to a seminar and all I get is one
idea.
It's worth my attending or if I go to a
seminar,
all it does is tell me what I already
know,
but I hear it another time and now maybe
by hearing and again I actually now use
it.
What a concept.
Then maybe I can make my life work.
And so I went for that strategy.
That repetition is the mother of skill
and I heard enough and I read enough and
I watched enough and I listened to
enough and I poured so much good stuff
in that you can guess.
Eventually good stuff started coming
back out.
In fact,
within a short period of time,
I became totally successful.
Now we all have our own definition of
success,
but you can guess what mine was back
then growing up pretty poor financially.
I ain't even know the answer was money.
I figured,
Hey,
if you make enough money,
it'll solve all of life's problems.
Is that true?
Of course not.
But if you make enough money,
at least you can arrive at your problems
in style.
You drive up in your limousine to handle
your problem.
It's a whole nother world.
Seriously.
My point is this.
I had really made it.
I thought by the time I was 19 years
old,
I went out and just use massive action.
I read all these books,
I listen to all this material and I went
out and just apply everything I could
and a short period of time I had this
big company.
I was written up in newspapers and
magazines is this young entrepreneur.
They called me wonderboy.
My Ego was exploding and I had what I
thought success was.
At that time of my life,
I had a lot of money.
I was making about $10,000 a month in
income,
which for a 19 year old kid for anyone
seems like a lot of money.
It seems like a lot of success,
but something interesting happened and
the interesting thing that happened was
I'd never had that level of success
before.
I had never had that many people liking
me and acknowledging me.
I'd never had that much money.
I'd never had that kind of experience.
It was beyond my comfort zone.
Now,
I'm not talking you about consciously
now see consciously I thought I wanted
more and better and all these other
kinds of things,
but subconsciously I believe that most
of us have a subconscious idea of what
we think we deserve.
I mean,
imagine it as if it's a thermostat
attached to your brain.
If we have a thermostat in this room and
we set it at 68 degrees and it's not hot
enough in here,
things aren't moving,
it's not warm enough and the temperature
drops down to 62 degrees,
what's going to happen?
The heaters kick on.
All of a sudden what happens?
Anxiety.
Your brain says,
Hey,
we got to make it better than this.
This isn't good enough for me.
And sure enough,
all of a sudden you get this push,
this drive to change things and that's
what happens in life when it's not good
enough.
When your life does not represent right
now what you think it should be like.
What's interesting though that most
people don't realize is it happens on
the other side too.
What do I mean?
I mean,
if you set it at 68 degrees and all of a
sudden things start going really well,
hey,
it starts heating up in here.
We start cranking.
If it gets up around 72 73 degrees,
what happens in this room?
The air conditioners kick on and you
begin to sabotage your own success and
you drop right back down to where you
subconsciously think you deserve to be
in your relationships and your economics
and your level of acknowledgement.
Does this make sense to you?
It doesn't make sense intellectually,
but it does make sense when you start
studying how human beings behave,
and that's what I did.
I began to sabotage my own success.
How I started not short for key
meetings.
I started treat people harshly who
didn't deserve to be treated harshly at
all.
I started eating like I was going out of
style.
I was never into drugs or alcohol,
but I use food like it was a drug.
If it didn't like how I felt,
well,
I just eat something.
I was going to change how I felt,
but then I looked in the mirror and I
was getting fatter and I felt worse so I
ate some more and it just didn't work.
I got caught up in this vicious circle,
so much so that within two and a half
months I gained 38 pounds.
That is not easy to do.
You have to eat tons of food and not
move very much to pull that off,
which I managed to do.
The bottom line is this though,
as I began to sabotage,
it didn't stop with me.
It started at affect everyone around me.
I fired almost everyone in my company.
I only had about three employees left
and I fired them too,
but every time I go there,
your fire,
they go,
I know and they just keep on working
thinking sooner or later things would
work out and I become sane.
I went totally broke financially and I
moved into a little 400 square foot
bachelor apartment in Venice,
California,
no kitchen,
washing my dishes in the bathtub,
waking up each morning with major goals,
things like what am I going to eat today
and what's going to happen to Luke and
Laura on General Hospital,
my favorite program at the time.
So how do I get to be here with you?
How did my life turn around?
Well,
the answer is it wasn't just buy more
information.
It wasn't just buy more technology,
although that made a difference.
What made the big difference for me as a
friend came by someone I hadn't seen it
about two years and the reason he came
by to visit me and how to track me down
and he couldn't call me on the phone
because my phone was disconnected at
this point.
My nickname had gone from wonderboy and
the newspapers to just,
boy,
I changed virtually everything in my
life,
from my emotions to my finances,
from my confidence to my physical
health.
How do they do it?
Well,
I use what I call the ultimate success
formula.
And here's what it is.
It has four steps.
If you want to create the success in
your life,
it always comes back to this.
You can use whatever technology you want
to reprogram yourself,
but these are the four steps for
success.
Step number one,
you've got to know your outcome in any
situation in life.
You've got to decide right now what I
want out of this situation in my life.
The more clear you are on what you want,
the more you empower your brain to come
up with answers.
There's an old phrase that may have been
overused,
but I think it's pretty accurate.
It says clarity is power.
You must get focused on what you want,
and in this tape program we have a goal
setting workshop that's going to help
you to get precisely clear and what you
want in your life,
mentally,
emotionally,
socially,
spiritually,
intellectually,
so that you have something that's a
driving force behind your behavior.
How can you use this first formula to
make a difference in your life right
now?
How could just getting clear and knowing
your outcome help you?
Well,
I believe when you know your outcome,
you've empowered yourself.
I mean,
let's say for example,
you're in the middle of an argument and
have you ever gotten caught up in an
argument where you're so caught up in it
that you forgot what you were going to
arguing for,
but you knew you had to win.
I know I've been there.
See if in the middle of that argument
you were to ask the question,
Hey,
what's my outcome in this situation?
You're going to probably find out your
outcome is not to argue.
The outcome you want is to resolve
something.
When you get focused on what you really
want out of a situation,
you empower your brain to use its
resources to produce results right now,
so get into that habit.
The habit of asking yourself,
what's my outcome and throughout these
30 days I'm going to constantly ask you
how can you use this?
What I just said?
What's useful about that for your life?
What is your outcome and applying this
in your own life,
it's critical to continually focus on
your target.
Even if you're just going to buy it a
visit with a friend on the way over to
see a friend,
ask yourself,
what's my outcome?
Maybe the answer is well,
just to have fun or to make my friend
feel really appreciated and loved.
Now,
if you know that your outcome,
your chances of having more fun or
making your friend feel love,
go up 1000% versus if you just go over
and hang out and wonder why your board
now I'm not saying you have to be so
goal oriented that every minute you're
trying to achieve something.
I'm just saying it's useful to let your
brain know the direction that you're
heading and everyone I know who
succeeded had to start with getting
clear on exactly what they wanted.
Here's step two of the ultimate success
formula.
By the way,
step one I did.
I decided what I wanted physically,
financially,
emotionally in my business.
I looked at everything spiritually and
once I knew I had the first stage and my
personal power.
Step two,
to tapping your power because you've got
to use it.
That is you've got to get yourself to
take action and move towards the
achievement of your goals.
Now,
what most people tell he is,
but I don't know what to do.
I don't know.
I never had.
What if I try and it doesn't work?
How I can say D is this.
If you're trying,
it doesn't work.
You got an education,
you're better off than where you were
before because you now know what doesn't
work and you'll probably make a
distinction or two that will help you
succeed even more.
Most people in life have no idea what
they want,
but worse,
a few people know what they want,
but they don't do anything about it.
They just sit around and hope or say,
someday,
honey,
we'll do this someday is now someday is
here.
I remember hearing a phrase years ago
that said,
the road to someday leads to a town of
nowhere and it's a place you don't want
to end up in,
so you've got to get yourself to take
action.
How do you do that?
You decide.
I hear people all the time saying,
well Gosh,
how do I change my life?
And my answer is decide to make a
decision right now.
You're not willing to settle for
anything less than you can be,
that you're not willing to live the way
you're living right now,
no matter how good it may seem that
you're going to push yourself to the
next level.
Demanding more from yourself than
anybody else could possibly expect is
true power.
And all it takes is deciding.
Remember the word decision and its
original Latin root means to cut off
from when you decide you cut off from
any other possibility.
The biggest trap that keeps people from
taking action is their fear,
their fear of failure.
They're fair success,
their fear of rejection or fear of pain,
their fear of the unknown.
The only way to deal with fear is face
it.
Look at Iti and take action in spite of
I'm sure you've probably heard of some
of the seminars I deal in which we teach
people how to break through their fears
and take action and at the end of the
seminar they get a chance to use what
they've learned to overcome a major fear
and literally walked through fire
between 802,000 degrees Fahrenheit and a
lot of people think it's crazy.
Go.
Why would you do a thing like that?
Well,
not to teach people new picnic skills
and if not mind over matter right now.
You could walk through fire.
I'm not encouraging you to make sure you
hear me,
but you could.
It's absolutely possible you don't need
me to do it.
You could also be up at 6:00 AM with
total passion for living.
You could also have the person of your
dreams be in your life right now.
You could also be earning what you're
worth.
You could also have more influence on
your children than virtually anyone
else,
but few people do.
It's not what we can do in life that
makes the difference.
It's what we will do and we don't follow
through because we don't know what we
want oftentimes,
and when we know we're afraid to take
action.
Listen,
fear can service.
Fear isn't all bad.
Say it'll make us pay attention as long
as fear,
as a counselor and not a jailer.
Make sure that you listen to your fear,
mixed some more distinctions and to get
yourself to take action in spite of it.
And I gotta tell you,
breaking through fear is like anything
else.
It's like a muscle in the beginning.
If you try and lift to heavyweight boy,
you might say,
Gosh,
I can't do this,
but if you start small and you build
every single day for like 30 days,
for example,
then what's going to happen is every day
you get a little stronger and pretty
soon it becomes effortless to do what
used to feel like it was impossible.
It's time for you to develop the muscle
of making decisions quickly and easily
and following through on them.
Here's the third key element to the
ultimate success formula.
Once you know what you want and to get
yourself to take action,
do your actions always work?
Of course not.
Most people in life fail much more often
they succeed.
In fact,
the most successful people are the most
successful people because they failed
more than anybody else.
I mean,
think about it.
Think about it in baseball and baseball,
a hall of Famer,
someone who's the best in the world at
what they do in the area of baseball,
they fail seven times out of 10.
How'd you like to have a life like that?
Bottom line is to get in the hall of
fame.
They only succeed about 30% of the time.
They failed more than 70% of the time.
And you know what?
That's how life is too.
Hey,
listen and doing this taping with you
and talking to you personally.
I may not sound elegant all the time
cause I don't care.
When I want to do is get across to you,
I want you to get the message in your
gut.
That's what matters to me.
If I say something,
it doesn't work,
I'll just move on to something else.
And I ask you to try the same thing in
life.
Most people in life,
out of their fear of failure,
don't try anything at all.
And that's ultimate failure.
You got to get yourself to take action.
You got to get yourself to follow
through and you gotta be willing to
notice whether it's working or not.
That's step three.
Notice what you're getting from your
actions.
In other words,
you know what you want.
You got yourself to take action.
Now notice,
is it working?
Am I getting closer to my goal or
further away?
Don't kid yourself or just keep taking
action because after all,
you work so hard to do it this way.
I might as well keep on doing it so you
don't want to get locked in a tunnel
vision.
Remember,
flexibility is power.
What you've got to do though is know
what you're getting.
I mean a standard examples.
Have you ever had somebody come up and
talk to them and they're going on and on
and on and you're trying to be very
polite and they mistake too.
You're being polite.
There's a way to speed up this formula
and that way is this.
Instead of just knowing what you want
and taking random actions,
you can use what I call role modeling to
accelerate pace of your success.
What I did is I said,
okay,
what do I want?
I'm 38 pounds overweight.
I want to lose this weight.
I want to be 38 pounds lighter and I
want to have more energy.
I want to feel more vibrant to my wife.
You can tell by my energy level that I'm
real low energy person now compared to
how it was then.
Seriously,
I decided what I wanted and then what I
did is I said,
okay,
I've got to take action,
but what actions should I take?
I didn't know.
I tried dieting a zillion times and you
know what?
It would work.
I would lose weight,
gain it right back again and I lose
weight and gain it back again.
So what I decided to do is instead of
just taking some actions and sooner or
later figuring it out,
I decided to use a role model.
I said,
let me find someone who's already
getting the results that I want.
Help me find out what that person is
doing and do the same things that is,
I believe that success leaves clues that
if people succeed,
it's because they're doing certain
things over and over and over again.
And if we do the same kinds of things
and we pumped the same kinds of seeds,
we're going to reap the same kinds of
rewards regardless of our age or
background or religion or color or
gender.
None of that matters.
What matters is the law works for
everyone and if you apply it,
it'll work.
But you've got to know what to do.
And so this program is the result of me
going out and modeling people that are
successful.
That is instead of reinventing the wheel
and having you and I kept doing trial
and error on everything,
I said,
hey,
let me find some of these already in the
results.
Find out what they do.
Do the same things,
get the same results,
speed up time.
You've got to remember,
knowledge is not power.
Knowledge is potential power.
I mean,
don't you know someone who knows what
they should do with their life,
knows they should change their life,
knows how they can change their life and
they still don't do it.
You know,
somebody like that maybe intimately,
like maybe you for example,
at times than the bottom line is
knowledge is not enough.
We've got to get ourselves to follow
through.
So what did I do?
I found somebody who had been overweight
like me,
had become thin and stayed.
Then for years I found out what this
person did and I did the same things I'm
going to teach you in this program,
what to do to do that.
It wasn't just dieting.
That's not enough.
As a result of following through and
taking the same actions,
I lost 30 pounds in 30 days.
I lost all 38 pounds in about seven
weeks and I haven't gone back.
And the reason is I didn't just change
my diet.
I learned to mentally condition myself
to feel differently about certain foods
I was addicted to.
So I no longer had a desire for them.
The things that used to push me over the
edge.
I did the same thing in the area of
relationships.
I found a man who had the woman of my
dreams and I talked to him and said,
hey,
how did you attract this woman?
And I talked to her and said,
why do you like this guy?
You know,
why are you in a relationship with him?
And I began to find out certain things
he did that made that relationship work.
And I started applying some of the same
things and I did the same thing
financially.
I went from a place where I had no
confidence in myself emotionally feeling
depressed to a place of total strength
and financially,
I mean a measurable change to say the
least.
I was broke living in my 400 square foot
bachelor apartment.
What happened in less than 12 and I
moved to my 1200 square foot apartment
major progress at the time,
three times bigger to about four months
later I moved to a 10,000 square foot
castle.
Literally a castle built in 1925 with a
big three storey turret overlooking the
crashing waves of del Mar,
California.
I don't tell you this to impress you.
I tell it to impress upon you how quick
would you can make changes in your life
if you learn to master this incredible
computer between your ears called your
brain.
That's what we're going to study.
We're going to study in neuro sciences,
the sciences of success conditioning.
That's what this whole program is about
and we're going to do it a little piece
at a time so it's simple.
If you will do that,
the culmination of the 30 days,
you will find that you've gone on a
mental diet that will change your life
forever.
If success is really the simple,
if you could go from being where I was
years ago,
broken every sense of the word
emotionally broke,
physically broke,
socially broke,
and financially broke.
Two Alfie in all those areas,
meeting my dreams,
becoming a millionaire in less than 12
months,
if that's really possible.
If it's really as simple as using your
personal power and being flexible in
your approach and modeling all
successful people.
If it's really that simple,
how come everybody doesn't do this?
That's a good question.
A lot of things in life are really
simple,
but people don't apply them because they
get caught up in day to day stuff like,
well,
you know,
I gotta pay my bills.
They get caught up in making that living
instead of designing the life and they
come to the end of their life and find
out they lived only one 10th of it,
not because they weren't intelligent,
simply because they didn't get clear
about what they wanted.
They didn't get themselves to
consistently take action and develop
that decision making massive action
muscle and their emotional body.
They didn't vary their behaviors and now
they're stuck.
It's not a place I think you want to be.
Otherwise you wouldn't invest in this
program and you wouldn't be taking the
time to listen now.
So what I'm asking you to do is break
through those fears that stop you.
And you know,
the biggest one that comes up again and
again and we've already mentioned,
is failure.
I want you to know that failure can be
your best friend.
I mean,
think about it.
The greatest successes in the world are
people who often had so much pain from a
failure that drove them to much greater
success.
Did you know those little three m
stickers,
for example?
Those ones that you see that you can put
there,
I think they're called postit notes.
You can write on them and put them on
something and take it right off
instantly.
Do you know that was a result of a
massive failure by the chemist?
He was working at the time to create an
adhesive that would last forever.
Something that you could never pry
things apart with.
And as a result,
he came up with the stuff that didn't
work at all,
but he was smart enough to say,
Hey,
what can I use this for?
How can I use this suppose supposed
failure?
And he turned it into a multimillion
dollar business.
Lee Iacocca,
most people would agree is one of the
most successful role models in our
country.
Now I've got a question for you.
How can we sell successful?
Because he's a wonder kid.
Well,
yeah,
you could say that.
He worked for a company called Ford
Motor Company and he worked his way
through the ranks right up to the top,
worked his tail off,
was driven.
What really marked him his ability to
get people to take action,
his personal power.
He developed skill cause he's willing to
try almost anything.
He wouldn't accept no for an answer,
but you know what?
He had a little run in with a guy by the
name of Ford and he fired him and it
burned him pretty good.
Now I've got a question for you.
Do you think when this company named
Chrysler came by and they look like for
sure there was no way they could be
turned around.
Do you think if he hadn't been fired by
Ford that he would have taken it?
He might say,
oh,
of course you would.
That's the way we is.
Wow.
I don't know.
According to his wife.
She said at the time,
he said,
honey,
I don't think anybody could turn this
thing around.
She said,
boy,
I met Mr. Ford.
It'll be real happy to hear that that's
all it took.
He was so angry from the pain and
failure of his past,
quote unquote failure that he was going
to show him that it wasn't his failure,
that Mr. Ford made the mistake.
Another company into mentioned IBM.
It all started because a guy by the name
of Tom Watson who worked for a competing
company called NCR,
got fired by the CEO.
They're also,
he got so mad.
He said,
I'm going to develop a company that will
dwarf yours someday.
See,
welcome frustration.
I got to tell you something.
When I get frustrated,
I've learned to get excited.
I learned a literally condition myself,
so that frustration creates excitement.
You know why?
Because I'm frustrated.
I know I'm about to have a breakthrough.
It means my brain is searching.
If I get confused about something,
instead of going,
I'll never learn this.
My response to that is,
Hey,
I'm about to learn something because my
brain is searching for a new answer and
if it keeps searching and it's going to
come up with one,
I believe the emotions that many of us
consider negative like frustration and
rejection and pain can be our greatest
friends cause they can drive us to
success.
You know what?
I think one of the things that happened
for a lot of people when they get
successful is they get superstitious.
It's like it works so hard for the
success and I now finally have it so all
of a sudden they don't change.
They don't vary their behavior.
They kind of like want to stay the way
things are.
They get incredibly conservative and
they miss out on the juice of life.
Stay out of the trap.
Listen,
when people succeed,
they tend to party.
When they fail,
they tend to ponder and now the
pondering.
Many times we create our greatest
successes in life.
Just remember,
it's impossible to fail.
If you try something and it doesn't
work,
just try something else and learn
something from what you just did.
As long as you learn something you've
succeeded.
Something else I want to remind you of
as well and that is sometimes people
say,
well Gosh,
I'm gonna do these exercises.
I know I'm going to be better physically
and emotionally and psychologically you
don't feel more confident but I want to
work on my career.
I want to take my business next level.
I want a business program.
When they tell you what personal power
is one of the most powerful business
programs because it deals with the
source of all your business,
just you.
When you're in better shape suddenly and
negotiate more effectively.
When you're in better shape,
your creativity flows.
When you're in better shape you're a
better manager of people.
That's why if you saw the infomercial,
which is how I assume you got to this
program,
then you saw people like for example
Bill Farley as Farley industries
endorsing this program saying is one of
the best business programs they ever
went through.
Well,
that's because bill became a billionaire
before the age of 40 all by using these
personal power type of techniques.
So I want you to know is very business
oriented or a Bill Nicholson,
you know,
he's a turnaround expert from major
corporations.
You know,
in the early eighties he took on a major
corporation that was losing $1 million a
day and turn it around so that within
four years it was doing more than $4
billion in revenue in the highest net
returns of the history of the company.
So I want you to know that bees,
people endorse it because it works if
you're a little bit skeptical,
I understand that.
But understand changing yourself as the
first place to change in your career and
changing your business right now.
As this tape ends,
I want you to do your first assignment
really simple.
Remember I told you the way to build a
muscle so that you're really strong,
it start small and build.
So we're going to start with something
really simple.
I want you to think of two actions
you've been putting off.
Two things that you should do.
Two things that you need to do,
but you keep putting it off.
Maybe it's a phone call or two,
maybe it's somebody a you've had some
poor communication with and you need to
clean it up,
but you're not doing it.
Maybe it's just going in the house and
cleaning it up right now.
Maybe it's some kind of report you need
to do.
I don't know what it is,
but right now I want you to think of
what are two actions you've been putting
off that if you were to take them now,
it would increase the quality of your
life.
Either simply were just increase the
quality of your self esteem because you
feel good because you actually fall
through,
or maybe even more powerfully.
What are two decisions or two actions
you could take right now that would
immediately change the quality of your
life?
Maybe it's the stop smoking.
Maybe it's to eliminate certain kinds of
food.
But if you are going to do something
right now that was going to change your
life,
what are those two actions?
And what I want you to do is decide,
remember to decide,
means to cut off and the other
possibility to resolve once and for all.
This is it.
There's tremendous power in that.
Start with something small if you want
and then build.
But right now,
write down two decisions you've made and
then take action on them immediately.
I mean,
right now,
I mean even before I finish talking
here,
stop the day,
pick up the phone and make that call
you've been waiting for.
Do not put it off another minute.
I don't care what it takes.
There's power and momentum.
I'm a big believer that once you set a
goal,
once you make a decision,
you should immediately in that moment do
something to start making progress
towards it.
That way you can't cop out later on or
get caught up or lose your momentum.
So please do it now.
And I know not all things can be done
right now.
So maybe it's something you have to do
tomorrow morning,
but whatever you're going to do,
make the decision and then commit to
follow through and then check in
tomorrow.
Cause this is the first step to grabbing
your personal power.
And remember,
there's no way to fail.
You might say,
well Gosh,
well if I do this and it doesn't work,
what if I tried this and it doesn't
happen?
Hey,
what if I screw up?
Then screw up big,
go for it.
Do a big screw up because then you'll
learn something.
Hey,
remember success in life as the result
of good judgment,
good judgment.
It's usually the result of experience.
Experience is usually the result of bad
judgment.
So if you've got some bad judgment,
it doesn't work out.
You'll learn something and I'll make you
more successful in the future.
Just go for it.
Don't be afraid.
Make it happen.
And you may say,
well,
it's such a little thing to do.
I'll do it later if it's a little than
do it now.
Don't put it off.
Okay,
I'm on your side.
Hey,
what I'm trying to be here for you is a
good coach.
You know,
I don't care how successful you are,
we all need a coach.